Jesus Christ did you see that no you
didn't cops come right away
[ __ ] in the back you're 16 it looks
creepy it sounds creepy
all right license plate your name is
Peter Reid if you flood a thunderstorm
it took shelter in an abandoned banker
as soon as you were inside the door
close behind you god damn but what a
bummer
that always happens you have your
headlamp with you oh well that's good
some food and some water you go find a
way out of the bunker
batteries don't last forever
that's an evil II me SD f here we go
what is happening I love this game so
far
oh I forgot the flashlight in to rotate
yeah [ __ ]
didn't I play this going to meet UN's
Isis pray to God I play this horror
games becoming so much in like yeah I
can't even tell anymore
Oh Oh press it open closed or all your
[ __ ] mind and your battles hello
someone took a piss in the sink that's
nasty
I don't close me out someone took a piss
in the shower yeah damnit bucket
hello bucket High House you got that
there got betting yeah
have a great day pets play again what am
i doing in here this is Jim McGinnis man
oh good
coffee mug and it still has coffee Diary
of Josh Walker I fled a storm took
shelter in this abandoned bunker as soon
as I was inside the door closed behind
me now I can't open it the door must
have locked automatically when it closed
there's a kiln in the door but of course
no key
he left his coffee too and I didn't pee
in it though so that's ok now where is
that key
I mean coffee I mean you're in what Oh
how's that tie up in our sense we're own
does today's hello damn I'm supposed to
attend a conference call tomorrow at
10:00 p.m. I need to find a way out of
here huge thanks to have Benton
flashlight the what a blimp there's no
emergency exit no windows I could have
been far too easy wouldn't it claw start
searching for a key I need to find a key
all right so we found wasn't she where
would I be inside my glee and Michael
yeah I mean my pee pee all right good
you're not tired yet so I can go to
sleep what the [ __ ] I'm gonna go to
sleep in a class like that that's
redonkulous I am now search for now Row
two but two haven't be able to find the
damn tape I have a wrench if I had a
wrench that maybe couldn't remove this
curse of course I do not have a wrench
with me who takes a wrench and a hike
right I do it's my friend wrenchy she's
great someone is a bit prejudiced so far
this game has greeted me with a lot of
empty and a lot of nothing
so far I'm not a fan of it did I copy oh
my god a coffee cup moved oh my god what
am I doing here Bros kitchen
I have no watch but I assume that it's
almost midnight and I must have missed
the conference call
damn I was about to get promoted I'll
take a nap here I'll take a nap
continues fresh well continue searching
for the key when I wake up what if there
is no key man you dumb met that coffee
cup moved oh my god Becky what's you
okay I don't have any fuses so you know
okay so only one at a time
let's do the whole way cuz I'm actually
you know what let's do the kitchen
that's where we got it right I'm gonna
see how it works and for that but I'm me
Simo oh yeah what's the point I'm doing
it huh what's up dude a coffee cup moved
I wish I had a map of this place job
loudly I'm dead I'm dead I'm dead
hello coffee cup hey wasn't it oh god
don't tell me I can die in this game
because I don't want to die am i'm
allergic today so it seems what I have
to do is hi Pat its hi die shut up find
the bedroom and go to sleep and probably
something really bad is gonna happen
there we I take a nap I would never
[ __ ] ever take a nap in a place like
this this guy is crazy with a capital K
really
I don't snore like that I promise why
are they noises what there's a note here
now when I woke out noises from the
outside room
I hope maybe someone had opened the main
door and to the bunker as soon as I went
outside my room the gnome rose I would
call it that mean - it's still closed
and there's no one around oh my god that
is creepy [ __ ] man hello oh god I got a
goose nips Oh what hello
what toilets don't weep thanks to me
they do I've just realized that some of
the crates are now have to stamp lies
that's aware yesterday it looks like
someone is search through them did
someone enter the bucket while I was
sleeping
could they still be in here Oh God if so
why are they so quiet are they hiding
from me i armed myself with a steel pipe
and tell them tell them to show
themselves but I don't have a steel pipe
bathroom please show me the power of the
style pipe I know karate except I don't
but you don't know that
hello oh god oh god what is that sound
coming from oh god this is [ __ ]
terrifying
goodnight ins Oh God oops
oh [ __ ] ah [ __ ] don't [ __ ] I'm a huge
baby don't don't they move that it's the
coffee cup I [ __ ] knew it
it's the [ __ ] coffee cup of course I
didn't get an answer therefore I went
ahead and search through the bunker
again there are not many places where a
person could be hiding in here but I
couldn't find anyone is it possible that
they were leaving the bunker just when I
woke up oh oh oh oh my god alright
alright
something is definitely near Oh what is
that
Oh copper cups copper cups you got me
the key
what is going on here
[Music]
coffee cups Shh Oh God now my good
flying help hello i'm swedish we don't
taste good i taste like pie like a
really nasty pie like the one your
grandma makes oh god oh god she likes
around my pine what is that one thing i
waited for like three hours
near the entrance and nothing has
happened i could hear was the sound of
rain while I was waiting I started to
wonder okay what were they doing in here
were they looking for something is there
something of value in here okay I'll now
get up and stretch through the bucket
again maybe I missed something probably
did sir the handle is jammed
Oh God what's in there what's in there
oh god oh god what the [ __ ] was that
that was definitely an evil eagle that
was two-barrel wanted that's not a head
ornament god damn it hello oh [ __ ] oh Sh
what the [ __ ] there was like this goat
UN's there before they totally charged
someone is pulling an April Fool's prank
I'm sitting on the floor and it enters
again I expected a main door but no way
open it but that's not for that to key
in my head I'm going through the option
that I had unfortunate that's now that
many oh there we go
that's a locker oh my god chopsticks oh
no Dan the return to the bunker late
last night I know she would know to be
here I I know she shouldn't be here but
who cares
my men love her and so do i what we
offer her a safe and warm place to sleep
and in return she offers herself body
sounds try to me what kind of weird or
duty they have here and why did i unlock
a key for this that we had perverted
porn metal cable I guess it serviced
some kind of entertainment down here
I'll take it okay okay I find your
little note now watch let me go let me
go then barrels are [ __ ] [ __ ] let
me go let me go
I never you're I don't care yes I do
about getting hotter finish please cuz I
don't wanna die
oh we're gonna slap again oh good I
don't want to go to slap
by definitely or something now
I don't like this the note the note
changed again I didn't sleep well I was
awakened by the sound of something heavy
being moved it sounded a difference of a
shelf or a heavy wrong haha what did you
move your [ __ ] ass sellers this kiss
oh god more notes why is there a wall
here there was no wall here yesterday
this is not possible but this is a solid
concrete wall it used to be a hole made
followed by storage area now boyfriend
gone right I have my one oh god oh god
no god oh god oh god oh god use the
paper to protect myself what's going on
here the layout of the whole bucket
exchange of an egg the kitchen needs to
be downstairs and left are there no
polish at garden not only because my
name isn't mime and it can't be missing
person ball just let me go please
I don't play mind games unless they're
games cuz I play games every day
actually die die days nothing but throw
that who did that oh I'm not gonna check
out actually nevermind
Oh God dying and it's Noddy
Floyd flower frøydis that's a day if not
it throwing it oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
I'm sorry okay I'm so sorry I am very
sorry about that
No okay okay okay okay okay okay
okay okay okay okay okay okay okay okay
okay oh god oh god oh god oh god oh god
oh god oh god oh god oh god oh god oh
god oh god okay okay okay okay okay
hello okay for a moment oh shut up will
ya for a moment I thought this was
perhaps just a drum
I slept myself in the face a couple of
times but that didn't help I'm still
here it's really isn't happening what is
this place I heard something walking
around I have to hide no I'm not a fan
of hiding not at all Thomas missed the
main door is the way it used to be but
of course it's still on if it senses the
hallway got even narrower
my heart is racing I'm sweating in my
hands a-shaking was getting too much am
I having a heart attack I'm about to
have a heart attack
yo you got nothing son nothing oh god
I'm dead I'm so dead what was what what
was that that's totally a face giving me
a VJ that for a second
you are still here aren't you
I'm still here I feel oh god oh god my
hands are still shaking have to get out
of it now Trevor lives in the studio
front door abandoned
Oh God was it was doing the whispers
don't do the whispers please okay we
have the other place we didn't have go
in this here only one note I'm not alone
in here
I never was disturbing Sam Swiss me in
the doctor the boys are getting me out
of that iswhat's heavily I should drink
more but it's not what I left I gasped
for air it feels like I'm climbing
imagine
you know [ __ ] we are so [ __ ] press we
are [ __ ]
doctors in the baton toes I don't know
this is definitely different I did not
remember this at all this is picture the
same print good to meet spoons
neither do I believe in God nor do I
believe in ghosts but I swear that when
I approached our picture I saw a face on
it just for a fraction of a second but
it was there what is this place it was
that person in the picture right there
those spices come from I'm tired you
intimated oldest oh my god is that what
it means it's not what it means you
[ __ ] you can't just do that it seems
a bit Alan Wake inspired but it works
oh god not another one I should have
known it diana is a filthy spy femme
caught her when she tried to sneak out
of her early here early this morning she
tried to steal the map in some food
radiations rations she would pay for
this we trusted her and she betrayed us
at first we were sure we'll shake her
skull
Oh God let's go I'm not a find on this
place I've never been so I want to sleep
with the lights on tonight please yeah
oh gosh shot a shot you a filthy man
shut your mouth shut up shut it shut it
real good
Oh God I get it I get it I'm dad I get
it it's fun yeah so fun so fun for me
okay it's fun for me ah
Oh what what what what was that good
sighs Adam what they should bring I'm
Gina oh god oh god what was that
I'm going to sleep I'm taking a nap I am
done Maddie night have sweet dreams
anyone goes to sleep when they see [ __ ]
like that
I'm sure ah slept like a baby
okay no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no no no no not a big fan of this at
all
go back to sleep please go back oh god
oh god I'm so dead I'm so dead all right
hello [ __ ] accord
no I can't I can't I can't I can't I
can't no I can't
iPad Steve Jobs help me I think walls
getting larger
everyone is happening Oh God god dammit
everyone loves to cuddle I guess I think
God it was it was a wonderful nightmare
putting this abyss with me next the tire
of George I fell asleep again in my
dreams that summer said sitting in a
room in the walls removing the room with
skin smaller smile I woke up sweating a
screaming gut prayer after a week now I
ran out of water and food I hear someone
screaming again and again and again and
again and again
that son-of-a-bitch girl dead son of a
[ __ ] that son of a [ __ ] go huh
that son of a [ __ ] now for [ __ ] sake
for [ __ ] sake No hi I am I'm together
don't be jealous because we candles I'm
sure he still loves you
I'm sure oh god what are you doing
oh sorry
there'll be two try peered a little
thing there I have no water no food I'm
[ __ ] into a hole I'm [ __ ] in the
butthole I don't know where to go or
what to do or what to do go it's jammed
just like my sandwiches indoors God it
was always right here but now it's gone
what's happening to me might be punished
for something that I've done in the past
there's no way out I'll die in this hole
that's what she said oh god shut up I'm
honest about your bit done hello don't
kill me
I'm very nice I'm sure we can be friends
down here keep ourself company you seem
like you can need a friend I stopped
them around aimlessly this awkward
pictures now there are more of them are
they trying to tell me something I do
not understand
now they disappeared for me that's what
they [ __ ] dead you [ __ ] barrel I
don't think I don't see you oh there
they are oh my god oh my god oh my god
my god the sedge is holding a key itself
ring to me is this the key to the main
door the main door is gone is this a
joke Como Zoo Mia join me so this is
fetching one of the rooms oh there you
are oh god no that's like 2 mm now you
know what I'm busy I've got all right so
the key goes probably to there all right
fine you know what
desperate [ __ ] all right let's see what
we got in here
what more thing
why would I drag myself
what is happening I can't move
then I become a statue oh he said
welcome to the bunker I have a guy so I
became one of the spat cheeks
what the [ __ ] that was [ __ ] up well I
was really gay like it shut you showed
what sorry and just sound can be so much
more effective than just a lot of scares
on top of your face like it was really
good it was really [ __ ] scary
I had go sniped all over my body but I'm
not gonna show you thank you for leaving
like on this episode and for commenting
bros I see you in the next one
good job brofist